I spent the last 100 hours rereading the
entirety of the wano country Arc
breaking down everything in five parts
to settle the debate once and for all if
it was Godly writing or a complete
disaster starting with part number one
the setting the first thing that stands
out is the design of the country of wano
itself seeing wano's ruined yet
beautiful landscape again with fresh
eyes was a real sight to behold after
four years the chapters were Luffy first
set foot on wanu soil were like Distant
Memories and there was a ton of new
meaning in these early chapters that can
be gained with the benefit of hindsight
now just like how most locations in the
one piece World take inspiration from
real life places there's no exception
here and you can tell how excited Oda
was to draw his take on Edo period Japan
he revealed that his drawing of the
flower capital is one of his favorite
panels in the entire series to date we
also learned eduano consists of several
different regions each with their own
daimyos as well as their own climates
udon Ringo and the flower Capital now
all of these are separate Islands joined
together by Bridges and while we don't
get to explore all of them fully what we
do see is exceptionally detailed wano is
absolutely brimming with culture customs
and characters just like its real-life
counterpart in Edo period Japan wano is
an isolationist country its culture was
allowed to develop without much
intervention from the outside world at
least until kaido and Orochi came to
power whereas many other countries in
the one piece World interact with each
other through events like the reverie or
trading wano has closed its borders to
the outside world completely and at the
introduction of the arc we also learned
that its borders are closed in a very
literal way when we see that its land
mass has risen high above the sea
surface the crew has to ascend a massive
waterfall in order to even get to wano
in the first place and once they do they
find an expansive freshwater sea set
high above the grand line now when we
first encounter wano through Luffy's
eyes we see a wasteland we've known
since Punk Hazard and resrosa that kaido
was supplying weapons and arms to the
black markets but once we see a
Countryside littered with smoke stacks
devoid of food and polluted with toxic
streams we see just how dire the
situation truly is kaido's influence has
turned this place into a true Wasteland
wano has become a land of extreme
inequality commoners like the girl otama
the first Ally that Luffy ever meets in
wano starve and thirst they have nothing
soon within the ways of kuri we find
okobore Town literally The Leftovers
town because the residents there subsist
off of the scraps remaining from
neighboring bakura town a home for
orochi's allies and officials in curry
but even more lavish than bakura town is
the flower Capital orochi's base of
operations we see the children of the
city being indoctrinated in school rooms
being taught supposed evils of the
Kazuki Clan and lifting up a road she as
a hero and in the city we see many
symbols of feudal Japan glamorous oirons
parade through the streets as a result
the straw hats work undercover as
everything from Ronin to soba noodle
Merchants now through Odin's flashback
we get to see the unspoiled wano of 20
years ago while it wasn't a perfect
place its natural beauty flourished and
Odin helped to make it an even better
place he turned Curry from a lawless
land into a prosperous region it makes
it all the more painful than when we
flash back forward to the raid on
onigashima where we not only see Odin's
inherited will but we recognize the land
the home that kinemon and the rest of
the nice gabbards are fighting for now
when we look to the coast in the
distance their looms an ominous skull
onigashima it's a constant reminder of
kaido's influence on wano the Beast is
always there always watching ready to
inflict further Terrors upon the
mainlands and onigashima is also a great
reminder of another feature of wano
settings its ties to Japan
mythology primarily the most heavily
featured folk tales referenced
throughout the wano arc is that of
momotaro the story of omotaro the Peach
Boy features a young boy traveling to
Oni Island to combat an onion terrible
monster from Japanese mythology with the
aid of a monkey a dog and a pheasant and
he befriends these Animal Companions by
feeding them kibi Dango dumplings and
the connections to one piece are obvious
they have momotaro but we have
momonosuke who leads wano with the aid
of Monkey D Luffy Yamato whose Zone
transforms them into a dog and the bird
is most likely Marco who turns into a
phoenix other myths that are referenced
are the multitude of Yokai that appear
when big mom makes new homies during the
raid on onigashima the character black
Maria is based on a Yokai called the
jorogumon a spider creature that takes
the form of a beautiful woman her weapon
oneido is based on a Yokai called
fittingly one Udo a large hat encased in
a flaming wheel another myth that's
referenced comes at the very beginning
of the arc with the carp ascending the
waterfall because it's said that a carp
that reaches the top of a waterfall will
become a dragon think Magikarp and so
that same myth is subtly referenced when
we learned that kaido's dragon fruit is
actually a model of the fish fish fruit
now throughout the entire araguano is
filled to the brim with references to
history and mythology of Japan however
for all the things that we got in this
Arc there are still Mysteries
surrounding wano country for instance at
the end of the arc kuzuki Sukiyaki
reveals the remnants of an old owano
deep beneath the freshwater sea and
hidden beneath the country itself is the
ancient weapon pluton while also left
wondering how the continent of wano
formed in the first place how were the
distinct Islands brought together does
it have something to do with the
continent polar ores and could the skull
that makes up onigashima be a relative
of this leave it to Oda to always have
us searching for more answers it's clear
though that even though we weren't 100
for longer than any other Island we'll
be seeing it again before or the series
is over so I think it's clear that wano
from a World building perspective is
probably one of the most beautiful
things that Oda has ever created but
there are four more points to break down
before we can actually cast our final
verdict on this Arc and one is about the
most controversial things about wano
that almost ruins the manga so let's
talk about part two the characters with
our setting now established it's time to
get into some of the amazing new
characters that we meet in wano as well
as some of the familiar faces that we
now got to know better and then had
fantastic character arcs and boy were
there a lot of characters some silly
some tragic and many many that will
never forget now rereading the entire
story and seeing the familiar faces
again was like meeting up with long-lost
friends some of whom you meet with joy
and some of whom you can never see the
same way again for example on my second
journey through wano how could I see
yasuye without thinking forward to his
tragic ending how could I see chondro as
part of the scabbards without gritting
my teeth at his eventual betrayal Oda
has written some of the most lovable and
endearing characters to date in this Arc
and it was a true pleasure rereading
them but again this is probably the most
controversial Arc in one piece and I
can't help but think that Oda made some
baffling choices with his characters as
well and even though I trust in oda's
Godly writing abilities for the future
of the story I still question some of
the turns that these characters took
first of all we have a massive
Supporting Cast background characters
that didn't play a major role in The Arc
but that added a lot of flavor to wano
we have regular citizens like those of
the flower Capital the oirens Yakuza and
the townspeople celebrating the fire
Festival the other tragic citizens of
ebisu town cursed to laugh forever we
even have a small Cameo from minatomo
the carpenter who's a relative of but
not the same inatomo who was an SPS gag
who fixed the door off screen in an
early panel of parties bar we have
colorful combatants like a roach cheese
on your bunch of ninjas there are the
giant numbers the pleasurers and best of
all the gifters a fattery enemy class
made exclusively so that Oda could
design the most cursed looking animal
human hybrids possible most of the
supernovas also make an appearance here
in wano as well we have basil Hawkins
finally taking on an important story
role early on in the arc as one of
kaido's Headliners very literal here
because of the lines on his head
somebody called Yugi Moto because this
member of the worst generation believed
in the heart of the cards right to the
very end unlike kit whose Alliance he
betrayed to join kaido he didn't have a
strong enough will of his own instead he
served who he perceived to be the
strongest both for his own advancement
and for his own Survival mostly
scratchman and poo was another notable
underling of kaido here though he didn't
play into the arc as significantly as
Hawkins I would say while he did
absolutely show off his mad DJ skills
and in the anime introduced us to the
number one Club Banger of the year he
just couldn't stack up to his peers when
it came in time for combat now while
Hawkins and the pool went where they saw
themselves as most likely to survive
breaking under the superior strength of
kaido X Drake had a completely different
approach learning that he was secretly
still a marine and undercover with a
secret sect called sword was a huge
Revelation that birthed tons of new fan
theories and online speculation and in
the end we got to see sword go against
Shield or CP ages zero fun fact Aegis is
a Greek word for shield if you didn't
know however the real star amongst the
supernovas were used as kids Trafalgar
law and killer especially killer
arguably he shined more as a character
than his own Captain I would say of
course we got to see the law that we
were all accustomed to crafting plans
only to get aggravated with Luffy
causing them to completely implode and
we got to see kit and Luffy's headstrong
personalities clash in a contest for the
most stubborn pirate on the island the
trio that first joined forces on sabaori
archipelago even if only briefly finally
took on the mighty yonko and we got to
see law and kid tag team the night
Unstoppable big mom killer though was a
real threat he tragically eats a smile
in order to save his captain his turn as
kamazole assassin for Orochi Landing
some wild moves on kaido during roof
peace and his clever strategy for
defeating basil Hawkins Killa was a real
pleasure to get to know this Arc pun not
intended even karibu helped a little bit
by giving Luffy all of his swamp meets
actually any other phrasing than that
would be better the meat that was inside
of his swamp and of course we have the
major players of wano who are invested
in the major conflict starting with the
supporters of wano we have a large cast
of standout figures there's hyogoro who
stepped in for Rayleigh and gave Luffy
the training montage that he needed in
order to fight one-on-one with a yonko
and who could of course forget otama the
first person who Luffy meets in wanokuni
and an emotional focal point especially
in the early part of the arc not only
does this future bewitching kunuichi
give us a host of animal friends like
the kumaino and well speed she ends up
turning the tide of the raid with the
most convenient devil fruit ever for
combating an army of Zone users Tama is
truly a fantastic character not only is
she adorable she was literally the raid
Saving Grace she's the first of two
characters connected to Ace and she's
emblematic of a central theme Here
hunger and so on multiple levels she
gives wano more personal Stakes for
Luffy as he fights against kaido in many
ways with her wanting to travel to Sea
when she's older she's just like Luffy
when he was a kid too with Ace and Luffy
acting as her Shanks another emotional
center of the arc is
the former daimyo of Ringo now his
relationship with the citizens of Town
particularly has adopted daughter Toko
as well as his Misadventures with Zorro
during Act 2 are a true highlight of the
arc his heroic sacrifice in order to
rescue the raid's chances make him one
of the most memorable characters of wano
by far among the most powerful allies
from wano on the other side of the
Samurai Ming pirate Alliance are of
course the nine scabbards Odin's own
retainers all of these characters stand
out in our fully developed personalities
especially kinemon who's been with the
crew for most of One Piece Post Time
skip nekumamushi inorashi raizo Kiku izo
kawamatsu Ashura doji denjiro and
kinemon and let's not forget the bonus
member shinobu and even though during
the arc it didn't feel like it they
really had a lot of memorable moments
like collecting all their allies like in
the Akida Kurosawa film one of oda's
major influences for the arc the
momentous battle against kaido the Epic
tsunachi moment another 7cm Samurai knot
in seeing the grave markers of the
scabbards who didn't survive I mean this
group practically a second crew shined
throughout the one Arc as they fought to
uphold the Kazuki Legacy and really all
their stories flow a lot better with a
second reread there are a few other
notable allies on the side of the Lions
who are not from one of themselves
however most notable was Marco the
Phoenix recruited by nicomamushi to join
into the battle he had a legendary
moment when he knocked big mom's crew
off the waterfall a second time still no
word what happened to that crew either
he also held off two yonko commanders
simultaneously and made sure that Zorro
made it in time for roof piece the minks
were also a crucial part of the team you
couldn't have a samurai mink ninja
pirate Alliance without them primarily
carrot and Wanda featured heavily in
their match against pero Sparrow carrot
despite getting the loss here ended up
with the crown of Zoe So since she
apparently didn't get to become a nakama
at least she got that going for her
which is nice and of course we have the
kozuki clan themselves kozuki Sukiyaki
in the disguise of tenguyama hitetsu who
has gone into a life of Hermitage after
orochi's takeover Kazuki hiori forced to
live in Disguise for decades as the
Curtis and kumurazaki waiting for her
opportunity to end orochi's wrath kozuki
Toki a time traveler from the void
Century who we'd better learn more about
soon and one of the Highlight characters
of The Ark and really after all this one
piece overall I think momonosuke he's
just a scared little kid but in this Arc
he had to grow up fast literally to
carry on the legacy of his father and to
protect his country our sniveling scared
little Momo became worthy of the title
of Shogun a dragon that would actually
protect the country instead of
destroying it and of course one of the
greatest allies to the alliance was Odin
himself now we didn't learn that this
character even existed until we were
already at the raid onigashima but they
quickly became a fan favorite and a
candidate for the next Straw Hat kaido's
son Odin also known as Yamato now Yamato
was a powerful force in the story from
their first introduction and one of my
immediate favorite characters of the
entire Arc proudly declaring to Luffy
that they would be joining the crew with
the help of Odin's lockbook and the
backstory with Ace this character
brought on huge story Revelations and
immediately became a fan favorite not to
mention that Yamato went Toe to Toe with
kaido through the use of their awesome
okochinomakami mythical Zone dog fruits
and in the end for some reason they
didn't sail away with the straw hats so
we can only hope that they and our other
favorite yonko-san katakuri joined the
straw hats under the banner of the grand
Fleet someday but we're gonna have to
get back to this development later
finally though we have the original
Kazuki Odin as well former Shogun of
wano crewmate to Roger and Whitebeard a
witness to the one piece and all arounds
the Giga chat of One Piece Odin would do
anything for his crew and his country up
to and including being boiled alive and
taking it in strides villains well first
of all if you're not subscribed after
watching this far you are the real
villain here but so are the incredibly
powerful antagonists of the wano arc the
straw hats and all their allies actually
managed to take down not one but two of
The Fearsome Emperors of the sea
anarochi kaido's crew had a ton of
combatants for the alliance to go up
against the Toby Robo stood out as
having some supremely interesting
characters though I felt like they were
not developed as much as they could have
been we had met page one back in act 1
but we also got a battle between two
absolute tanks with sazaki versus
Frankie the headstrong all team made for
a dynamic and entertaining character and
a terrifying threat for Nami and usop
like Maria gave us a wonderful Sanji
moment as well as the Robin fight that
we've been waiting for all our lives and
the xcp9 agent who's who gave us the
first Whispers of the sun god Nika
setting up for Luffy's big gear 5 reveal
and speaking of Cypher pole agents cp0
served as a real wild card during the
entire raid on onigashima their pursuit
of nicarabin and the interference in
Cairo and Luffy's fight made four huge
moments of tension and twists in the
story overall I'd say now they weren't
the only representatives of the world
government to show up in wano though
because in the final chapters we also
finally got the reveal of aramaki aka
the new Navy Admiral green ball his
Forest logia devil fruit devastated the
remnants of kaido's crew and could have
dealt the same blow to the scabbards if
it weren't for shanks's interference the
real star of kaido's crew were the
All-Stars Jack had his moments on Zoe
and unfortunately was sidelined during
most of this Arc but queen and king were
fantastic characters here Queen Who
provided a lot of comic relief and his
funky disposition brightened the udon
prison section of Act 2 and his personal
connections to judge Vin smoke gave
personal Stakes to sanji's fight against
him King's identity and backstory as a
lunarian raised a whole new host of
mysteries and theories for the future of
the series and of course Oda treated us
to some truly amazing lessons in biology
with the bizarre ancient Zone Powers on
a roachy's side of things conjuro's
betrayal of the nine scabbards was
wonderfully executed even if many of the
community had already correctly
predicted that he was gonna be the
traitor kandra also kidnapped Momo
adding to the tension of the raid and
left the rest of Odin's retainers in a
state of complete emotional disrain for
me personally this is kind of up here
with Squad attacking Whitebeard as one
of the greatest betrayals in all of One
Piece so far and of course we have
Kendra's Master the sniveling Orochi
himself he was something of a spandom to
kaido's Rob Luchi here and much like
spandom resurfacing as a part of the 0
Orochi just wouldn't die but at least a
good part of his eight-headed devil
fruit is that we got to see him be
decapitated so many times I mean I can't
even begin to count them after all one
death just wouldn't have been enough for
this despicable character and finally we
had the two yonko themselves big mom and
kaido big mom already had her time to
shine on whole kick Island and certainly
had some ups and downs here as well I
mean there really weren't too many fans
of the Amnesia subplot for instance
including me however when it was finally
time for roof peace and the battle
against kid and lob she really showed
exactly why she holds the Fearsome title
of yonko she also of course brought
along her eldest son perospero who did a
lot of his usual licking and being a
general creep I guess I mean he did
manage to have some really interesting
clashes with carrot Wanda and even Marco
briefly however in the end he was no
match for a vengeful Neko mamushi kaido
of course was the leading villain of the
Ark absolutely fearsome in his power a
looming Unstoppable dragon and force of
nature here he wanted to crush wano and
plunge the world into war in many ways
his character remains mysterious up to
today because we know from his
introduction that he has a death wish he
jumps off sky islands for fun he's an
alcoholic often spilling into clumsy and
excessive displays of emotion but it's
all very superficial really he prizes
strength Above All Else he allows his
underlings to challenge each other to
climb up the food chain and become
All-Stars and he also believes in a fair
fight interestingly enough the scar that
he received from Odin on his chest
haunts him knowing that he didn't win
the fight fairly due to interference
from the kuruzumi clan which is nice
foreshadowing for that exact same type
of interference in the fight with Luffy
that leads him to showing no mercy to
the zp0 agent who interrupted them but
really so far what we've gotten his
backstory felt fairly standard compared
to for example the tragedy of big moms
so we can really only hope that when we
learn more about Roxy's back we get to
learn more about kaido and his true
motives as well the only question is
isn't it kind of too late at that point
and lastly we of course have the straw
hats and an arc so saturated with
characters many didn't exactly get a ton
of time to shine on a second reread in
particular usop didn't have a lot of big
moments at all but I hope that this will
change in al-bath Brook 2 plays more of
a support role the entire Arc after
being the MVP of whole cake Islands
however here are some of the highlights
the straw hats gave us jinbei finally
officially joined the crew and gave his
racist opponent the smackdown that all
Races deserve Choppa did what Chapa does
best doctoring against the ice only
plagues but also thanks to his Rumble
ball field match against Queen We were
also treated to Baby Geezer Chopper
though his Rumble balls I kind of would
have wished would play more of a role in
an arc filled with Zone types and let's
not forget that Frankie ran over a
yonko's face with his motorcycle Le
legendary Nami finally got her Luffy
will be pirate king moment as well as
becoming a surrogate mother to Tama
Robin got a fantastic new power up and
showed the fandom once and for all that
she's a force to be reckoned with Sanji
unpacked a ton of family trauma finally
here and got some super new bones Zorro
literally conquered the Grim Reaper got
conquerors haki and received a new sweet
sword but we learned surprisingly little
about his Heritage after it was strongly
hinted that he had some sort of
connections to the shimotskis which is
disappointing and Luffy well Luffy
became a yonko he became Joy boy he
unlocked Ryo Advanced conquerors hockey
and gear fifth he took down kaido and is
now one of the strongest powers in all
of One Piece and Luffy's growth as a
leader in this Arc brings us to part
three the themes of wano now wano like
so many one-piece Arts before it is a
story that has something to say has a
really strong core message in fact it
has a whole lot to say now that we've
talked about the setting and the
characters it's really time to explore
the themes that wanokuni has to offer
because on the first read-through
especially reading the story weekly it's
really hard to see what Oda is building
towards we're so invested in the
moment-to-moment action the constant
twists and turns that it's hard to see
the forest for the trees and I'm not
talking about the forest logia that he
was building to though it was nice to
finally meet aramaki now I'm talking
about the messages that Oda is
deliberately putting into the story and
wants you to carry with you now some of
these are themes that we're already
familiar with that you already know from
one piece but in a remixed and new and
interesting way and some of the themes
were completely new and unique to this
Arc but backing up and looking at wano
all at once the impact of the story is
felt on a whole new level let's start
with a really familiar one the concept
of inherited will shows up in almost
every Arc of the story the red scabbards
and especially momonosuke inherited the
will of Odin Momo always thought to be
strong like his father to be the Shogun
that the country needed but he's always
been overcome by his fear fear of
heights of kaido of letting his own
people down who depend on him however
when kaido chained him to a cross and
gave him the opportunity to renounce his
family name Momo stood on solid grounds
and wore the banner of the kozuki
proudly later in the arc he realized
just how important he was due to Yamato
giving him his father's logbook he
learned that for some reason crucial to
the coming of the Dawn he has to remain
alive then thanks to shinobu's Powers he
literally grew up and became the adult
that wano needed he overcomes his fear
of using his Dragon form and flying to
help Luffy in the fight against kaido if
you can call what he does overcoming his
fear however like Luffy says Momo has
nothing to be scared of after biting an
act yonko EK Momo even learns how to use
his flame clouds to save the flower
capital from being crushed under the
falling Island onigashima and there's of
course the entire thing of Luffy and
joyboy here as well another reoccurring
theme is the sins of the father
characters like Ace the son of the
pirate king had to deal with the burdens
of being born into notoriety of a world
having it out for him just because of
his parentage in different ways Rob and
Frankie and Chopper also had to come to
learn that it's not a sin to exist in
this Arc next to Momo Sanji came to
better terms with his Vin smoke Heritage
as his new power is awakened he feared
becoming an emotionless monster like his
brothers but instead he realized that
just because he was born a Vince smoke
doesn't mean he can't be completely his
own person orochian kanduro represent
another side to this theme their Clan
the kurozumi were prosecuted for the sin
of one of their forebearers and through
them we see how destructive a cycle of
hatred and revenge can actually become
it can swallow an entire nation without
something to break that cycle the hearts
of the kurosumi were consumed by revenge
and like their namesake they burnt
another very often reoccurring motive
that appeared in wano a lot was the
theme of imprisonment now throughout one
piece prison has always been a feature
of several arcs what better to contrast
against the story's central theme of
Freedom am I right in Alabaster the crew
was imprisoned by crocodile in anoslobby
Robin was held captive impell down was a
whole Prison Break Arc in itself slavery
is a central theme of saba ODI
archipelago Amazon Lily and Fishman
Islands on hulkic island Luffy and Nami
were imprisoned by mondor and really
this isn't even close to being every
example we have in the story for this
once again imprisonment features heavily
here notably with the udon prison mind
plot where Luffy and kids spent a large
portion of Act 2 and Yamato's character
also suffers a very similar fate being
outfitted with explosive shackles and
sentenced to remain on onigashima their
entire life instead of voyaging out to
the Sea and as mentioned before Momo
stand in captivity after being kidnapped
by chondro is also another very strong
example of this I mean heck in a sense
all the people of wano are held captive
subjugated by the oppressive rule of
Orochi and the Beast Pirates thankfully
though they had a warrior of Liberation
to set them free then there is the theme
of leadership particularly the question
of what it means to be a good leader
Luffy and Odin while both bombastic
characters with some headstrong
similarities are heavily contrasted
against one another here Odin's
leadership style was to work endlessly
for his country and his followers he
wanted to support everyone and do it
independently even in his final moments
he holds them up so that they don't have
to burn with him now in the end of
course everyone does count on Luffy
defeating kaido but Luffy counts on his
crew and allies to help him accomplish
this just in the same way along the way
to the Rooftop top to confront kaido the
full force of the Beast Pirates try to
prevent him from ascending onigashima
but each time he's able to count on some
Ally to take on the foes in his way
kaido on the other hand of course has a
very different take on what it means to
be a leader and it's another central
theme of The Arc survival of the fittest
a philosophy of Might makes rights
kaido's crew is made up largely of
former captains who he beat into
submission whose will he literally broke
unlike Luffy who tries to empower those
around him to accomplish their
individual dreams and reach their full
potential kaido just drags everyone
weaker than him along in service of his
own desires and plans everything about
his crew reflects the idea of a
hierarchy purely based on strength and
power the roles on his crew are all
named after playing cards the numbers
Jack queen king all in ascending order
of strength the flying six are allowed
to challenge the All-Stars in combat in
order to flame spots for themselves here
they are the Beast Pirates the animal
King Pirates they're Primal and
prehistoric in their days the dinosaurs
were the peak of the food chain
everything else was beneath them though
maybe they are also meant to be relics
of a bygone era I mean Oda giving them
all ancient zones could also represent
an idea that their philosophy of
survival of the fittest is outdated to
be replaced by values that the straw
hats represent much much better such as
Liberty and equality after all the Beast
Pirates did include who's who an
outspoken racist against Fishman whose
views belong in the distant past as our
heroes usher in a new dawn of the world
and speaking of Who's Who while he's a
terrible person he's an excellent bridge
to our next theme identity who's who is
just one of many many many characters in
walnuts who have some sort of hidden or
secret identity this masked member of
the Toby Ropo was in reality a former
member of cp9 who after fail willing to
guard the Nika fruit from Shanks was
thrown into prison after his Escape he
started a new life in hiding with the
Beast Pirates another member of cairo's
crew with a notable hidden identity is
King underneath a whole lot of kinky
looking leather he hides the last
lunarion also an escapee from the world
government much like who's who and his
captain conjuro 2 hid his identity as a
kurosumi from the rest of the scabbards
even big mom lost her identity and sense
of self during the Amnesia subplot in
Odin's flashback kurozumi Higurashi uses
the money Malino me a fruit whose whole
purpose is to assume other people's
identities on the Alliance side of
things we have tenguyama hitetsu who was
secretly kozuki Sukiyaki he hid himself
away partly out of necessity for his
survival but also out of Shame for his
failure to allow wano to become what it
did we have killer becoming camazo
X-Ray's membership in sword and yasuya's
experience as the witching hour boy yeah
remember when that was a thing and even
onimaru transforms into yukimaru that's
like monk-like Yokai figure in the
beginning of the arc we see the straw
hats assuming new identities while in
hiding with names like Luffy taru and
Zoro Judo though it's no wonder that
they were found out almost immediately
when you really think about it however a
lot of sanji's role in this Arc revolves
around him hiding his identity a silver
mask or by using his invisibility but
ends with him claiming proudly who he
knows he is momonosuke 2 refuses to hide
his identity when he had the chance and
one of the clearest explorations of
identity in the wano arc comes from
Yamato as controversial as it might be
Yamato sees Odin as a hero to the extent
that they've claimed his identity as
their own the most glaring and obvious
theme throughout wano however is that of
hunger Luffy and Cohen literally just
left whole cake Island an entire Island
themed around edible stuff and food
which served as a clear contrast moving
from an island and overflowing with
sweets to a Barren Wasteland where the
citizens are all starving to death after
Luffy saves Tama from some lower level
Beast Pirates she feeds him a serving of
rice as a thank you it is then that he
tetsu reveals that this rise was the
most food that she'd got to have all
year which is just the sweetest and most
heartbreaking moment all at once to
drench her hunger she drinks from The
Poisoned river leading us to the bakura
and okubota town parts of act 1. the
Elites in bakura town hoard food from
their private Farm while everyone else
is starving but after Luffy gives a
beating to the sumo wrestler Yokozuna
and hold them they steal the treasure
barge loaded with food and give
leftovers town a feast that they will
never forget Luffy even declares this
early on in the arc that he'll turn wano
into a place where you can eat as much
as you want every single day Tama
receives Delicious ushiruku from suru
making it all the more meaningful when
the same dish causes one of big mom's
hunger pains when she has amnesia as
well as igniting Luffy's rage when the
Beast Pirates waste huge serving of it
during the fire Festival the smile
fruits also align nicely with the theme
of hunger as well Orochi cruelly feeds
the defective fruits to the citizens of
ibisu town so that they will be cursed
to always laugh despite living in
complete despair Killer 2 meets this
fate as well what began as a peculiar
trait of kaido's Pleasures had one of
the darkest twists in all of One Piece
in the end now thankfully that wano has
finally been saved it really has become
a place where the residents can eat as
much as they want every single day
especially thanks to Green Bulls kind of
replenishing of the entire Countryside
but it's now time to really talk about
what wano did very right and where it
really fell short of everyone's
expectations in part 4 the highs and
lows of the story now look I know that
in spite of much much fan speculation
also my end we didn't get a 5x structure
in mono the theory community in
particular earned a PhD in Kabuki
theater studies early on in the arc
before we learned that we just get a
really really incredibly long act three
however to appease the fan base's desire
for a 5x structure I'm happy to inform
you that we will have five acts to our
wano analysis so what made wano such a
controversial Arc what made some fans
love it unconditionally and others
basically threatened to quit the entire
story I mean simply by its length alone
wanna was bound to be an arc of high
highs and low lows it had some of the
hypest moments of the entire series to
date hands down but it also had moments
that really disappointed me in fans
things that made us question oda's
Judgment at times and things that made
us pray that we'll just revisit juano
before the end of the series to get some
closure on a bunch of things it is one
of the most divisive arcs in the series
with many online saying that it's hands
down the best Arc and others making the
Bold statement that it's the worst Arc
which I wouldn't go that far let's start
by looking at the lowest lows of this
Arc and we can't really talk about the
lows without talking about the lowest of
the All-Stars Jack after though we saw
Jack as this terrifying presence he was
the first billion plus Berry Bounty that
we saw in the series he terrorized the
minks on zou but thanks to sanisha he
never got to actually take on the straw
hats and so understandably in wano many
people were really excited to see Jack
In Action again but he was absolutely
steamrolled first he was easily defeated
by Ashura doji then during the raid he
was essentially off-screened by sulong
Inu arashi and nekomamushi and I feel
like after we'd seen them and the other
Ming suffers so much at his hands it
would have been nice to get a few more
panels at least to get some closure on
that entire storyline oh boy okay
um Amnesia just like Sabo before her big
mom got amnesia during this Arc and the
fanbase was not happy about it there
were a few highlights to the segment of
the story some gags with her befriending
Chopper and acting as a mother figure to
Tama that were honestly amusing and I
did enjoy those however Amnesia does
feel like a bit of a lazy and contrived
plot device very quickly and in this
case it didn't quite justify itself I
would say oh yeah and coming into wano
we all thought that this was going to be
zoro's Arc in the same way that whole
cake Island was sanji's Arc this turned
out to be not the case he had a fair
share of wonderful moments like slashing
a building in half at the beginning
receiving enma and his amazing feats
during roof peace however during whole
kick Island we learned a whole lot more
about sanji's backstory and got a great
deal of character development for him as
well Zorro wasn't really developed in
the same way here even though there were
some hints drop that he does have some
sort of close connection to wano
specifically to the former daimyo of
Ringo so it's surprising especially that
Zorro didn't visit riyuma's grave at all
like that was something I was 100
expecting to happen really the only
thing was we had a few characters
commenting on the significance of shoe
sui even claiming that Zorro must be a
grave robber for having it in his
possession however having first learned
about wano country through ryuma during
the Thriller bark Arc and ryuma being
connected to oda's original One-Shot
manga wanted many thought that we'd
learn more about this ancient warrior or
at least see Zorro pay his respects to
him and really it wasn't only Zorro that
got the short end of the stick here most
of the straw hats didn't have a ton to
do except Luffy of course we had an
incredibly inflated cast of characters
to juggle around here particularly with
the nine scabbards acting as major
players in this Arc since we had to meet
and develop every single one of them it
also meant less time for the straw hats
which was a bit disappointing because
with the attention being split here it
meant that not only the straw hats but
also the nine scabbards were not as well
fleshed out as they could have been
characters like carrot especially who
sailed with our crew for multiple arcs
in a row now did basically nothing
besides eating grass I guess oh yeah and
this is of course all of our favorite
topic this isn't a new criticism for one
piece of course Oda does not like to
kill off characters characters survived
the most impossible circumstances so
often that even when a character does
actually die most of the fan maze
doesn't even believe it at first I mean
take kaido and big mom as an example now
there were some good deaths in this Arc
yasui is crucifixion and all three of
rochi's deaths were all three greats the
surprise decapitation by kaido was
especially cool Orochi coming back
multiple times makes sense giving his
devil fruit I mean eight heads eight
lives and it does fit with his character
quite nicely as well just as he clings
to kaido for power he clings to life
he's a pest that you just can't get rid
of so thematically quite well done
kandra's artfruit does not play by the
same rules he also just keeps coming
back to combat the gabbards even after
multiple Death Scenes he becomes a
Strange Fire Monster seemingly out of
nowhere and unrelated completely to his
devil fruit powers and of course the
jury is still kind of out whether kaido
and big mom are actually dead I mean in
most series getting shot through the
Earth straight into freaking magma would
be a certain death sentence but we've
seen just how durable these yonko are so
I'll only believe it when I get an
arbitrary straight from Oda himself now
where deaths really become a problem in
this Arc is with the red scabbards in
the end two scabbards died during the
raid Ashira doji who sacrificed himself
to save the group from an explosion and
easel who died fighting zp zero
coincidentally these also happen to be
the two scabbards with the least amount
of characterization we didn't spend
nearly as much time with Ashura doji as
we did with the other scabbards like
rhizo nekumamushio in orashi or even
Kiku who he met right away in act 1 and
izo didn't and even meet up with the
group until the raid started itself we
only had a few scenes from marineford
and a little bit of Odin's flashback to
develop this character in particular so
even though tragic and nice characters
these deaths didn't really hit hard at
all to me personally least and so just
to spell it out openly kinemon and Kiku
should have died during the raid Oda
gave them amazing final moments only to
undo them chapters later by a
technicality I mean kinemon split a body
may have been lightly foreshadowed in
Punk Hazard but we've never seen this
impact with anyone else law has operated
on it did feel a little bit like an
[ __ ] you'd think that after three
arcs of walking around with his torso
lose it would have fallen off with
something a little bit lighter than a
full force hit from kaido I mean we have
been traveling with kinemon for all of
the new worlds losing him would have
been remembered as one of the biggest
emotional moments of the series and
instead it was reduced to a gag just a
few chapters later really a wasted
perfect death scene right there could
have been so good ah and you know that
this one was gonna come as well on whole
kick Island big mom had a full two
chapters dedicated to her backstory and
through these two chapters she became a
much more complex and interesting
character than anyone would have ever
imagined previously her background was
tragic and twisted and it helped Define
her as an antagonist and made us
understand her so so much better kaido
on the other hand as far as we can tell
apparently is a strong guy who's good at
War and loves to do war and wants to
start War he's always been that
apparently given Oda the benefit of the
doubt it's probable that we still gonna
learn more about it with Roxy's back
when we get that backstory but perhaps
the important bits of that story are too
crucial to Future mysteries for us to
know right now at this point but anyway
you cut it this backstory was just a
major letdown and a major disappointment
I mean come on come coming on the heels
of not only big mom but villains like
doflamingo who had received excellent
backstories and complex characterization
kaido's backstory left so much to be
desired especially after it was hinted
at that he was such a more interesting
and complex character than he seemed on
the surface really it ended up being
just a portion of a chapter and that
felt incredibly rushed and glossed over
so much of kaido's behavior and dialogue
is enigmatic his cryptic references to
Joy boy for instance super interesting
but for now we just don't know much
about what makes this villain tick which
you kind of need if you want like an
impact when he's defeated up until the
backstory he had the potential to be
remembered as the greatest one-piece
villain the series has seen so far but
it still feels like he's missing a few
essential pieces really so that was
maybe personally for me the biggest
letdown of the entire Arc or so I
thought but there is actually this I
forgot one of the major reasons some
fans look back on wano with whatever the
opposite of rose-colored glasses are is
that the very last chapter of the arc
left a lot of readers on a real real low
note and that's of course Yamato now
from their very first introduction
Yamato declared that they wanted to join
the crew we had every indication that it
was Yamato's goal to join the future
pirate king at Sea following in the
footsteps of Odin they said so 10 times
minimum it feels I mean this notion was
constantly reinforced and repeated right
up until the very last moment and then
out of nowhere in the very last chapters
of the arc Yamato just stated that they
had changed their mind and would now
stay to do sightseeing in wano they even
said they'd already talked to Luffy
about it an important conversation that
was just off screen and ended up making
the reveal incredibly jarring to follow
even though it's tragic and I'm very
disappointed with it the problem isn't
really that Yamato didn't join the crew
it's more that The Rock was pulled out
from us with such force and with no
warning it just doesn't feel like Oda
the master of foreshadowing really
foreshadowing this particular twist it's
not really similar to a situation like
Paulie where during the water 7 Arc it
felt like he might become the crew's
ship right before Frankie reveals
himself as the true candidate that was
some sort of misdirection but it had
plenty of lead up throughout the arc and
the progression felt really really
natural the entire thing here with
Yamato just this here just felt like it
came out of nowhere like Oda went oh
actually I don't want to bring Yama too
long and so it really left a lot of
Yamato fans including me feeling like
they've been slapped in the face now to
be fair a few chapters later we would at
least receive a better excuse for
Yamato's change of Minds I mean Yamato
staying in order to protect wano from
outside threat makes sense in comparison
to just wanting to explore the various
regions of the country I mean after all
the okuchi no makami Yamato's mythical
Zone fruit is a guardian deity of wano
however that doesn't change the fact how
the entire thing was handled especially
after all that setup and the fact that a
lot of fans were outraged by that sudden
twist now when you lay them all out like
that it does feel like wano had a lot of
negatives and that's true there are some
actual major downsides that detract from
an arc that was a real Contender for the
best one piece Arc ever however I want
to make the case that there were even
more positives here to look at just as
the lows in wano were really low the
highs were also incredibly high so let's
look at the most hype moments and the
biggest highs in the entire Arc the
first highlight we'll go over comes
towards the tail end of act one for
years we've been a little bit confused
about momonoska a little kid somehow
commenting that he knew Goldie Roger who
had died 20 years prior to this some
eagle-eyed fans figured out the time
travel twist but many casual fans were
really shocked to learn that some of
this scabbards had been sent forward in
time by a character called Toki now
similar to Amnesia time travel is a very
risky and difficult Trope to pull off as
well I mean we already talked about how
the big mama ninja surplot was not
received well at all and weaving time
travel into an already complicated plot
could have been disastrous let's be real
I mean you well know that time travel
has a way of completely unraveling
stories and creating a lot of paradoxes
that make it really hard to enjoy the
rest of the story luckily however Oda
sticking to his rule of time travel only
happening in One Direction helped him
avoid the problems with this particular
plot device the method he used to reveal
it ending a chapter with Luffy finding
the grace of his comrades was an
excellent way to frame that entire twist
I think also learning that kinemon Momo
and the others were lost in time added
new meaning to their Journey so far as
well every encounter with them gained
new meaning as we found out they weren't
only adrift in foreign lands but
literally out of place in time as they
went on their quest to recruit allies to
take on kaido the next highlight comes
directly after that reveal as well with
kaido's devil fruit reveal and the first
confrontation with Luffy honestly the
ending of act one was fire many had
assumed correctly that kaida possesses a
dragon fruit but there were a lot of
different theories floating around the
community before we finally got that
actual reveal however seeing kaido's
gargantuan Dragon form descent from the
clouds of Awana was really something
else entirely also in the anime I want
to say whether you saw that one coming
or not chances are you were awestruck
and intimidated by this BEAST's true
appearance it was really something else
well done then leave it to Oda to
completely subvert our expectations as
usual by showing us this massive monster
be absolutely plastered Luffy wasted no
time in trying to take on the huge yonko
but even his strongest strikes could
hardly face kaido Oda raised the stakes
once again by having kaido evidently
destroy the straw hats and the Heart
pirates with a blast breath aimed
straight at the remains of Odin's Castle
after Luffy had spent the last arcs
getting stronger and stronger eeking out
victories against doflamingo and
katakuri we realize just how much
further he still had to go when he was
literally one shot by a thunder bagua
Luffy did have one feat of his own
though showing that his Spirit would not
break he managed to activate conquerors
haki while being unconscious of course
leave it to someone like Luffy and kids
to be so headstrong that they turned
torture into a training montage I mean
using the sea Stone cuffs as Rock Lee
style training weights that is badass it
really goes to show just how willful the
supernovas are going through all that
training while being constantly set of
their energy I mean Luffy even got a
whole new muscle-bound makeover kyogoro
taking over as Luffy's temporary Mentor
in the prison mines was a highlight of
active for as well we finally learned
the secret of real or Advanced Armament
hockey and received answers to a whole
lot of mysteries for instance we learned
the secret behind Rayleigh being able to
remove exploding cuffs we also found out
why the yonko are so seemingly
invincible and how to actually penetrate
their defenses and I mean why buy a
punching bag to practice on when you
have a perfectly good big mom right
there good stuff okay now this is how
you do a death scene properly we didn't
know yasui before this arc when we met
him he was a silly guy character tagging
along with an irritating Zorro and in
perfect Oda fashion he disarmed us with
comedy before hitting us right in the
fields we slowly started to learn about
his relationship with Toko we learned of
his connection to ebisu town we learned
that he was the witching hour boy who
stole from The Ridge and gave to the
poor and eventually we learned that this
Goofy character was a proud and Stern
former daimyo of wano and after he
tragically sacrificed himself so that
the rate of yashima could still maintain
the element of surprise the citizens of
ebisu town gathered in the flower
Capital laughing uncontrollably what a
sad and tragic moment we learned the
depth of the torture that Orochi had
inflicted on wano when we found out the
terrible curse brought on by the smile
devil fruits and so EAA may be relative
of Zorro himself earned his place as one
of the true MVPs of wano a fantastic and
really heartbreaking moments okay so
it's a little bit unreal to think that
we saw Roger reach love tail for the
first time during the wano arc I mean we
learned that the island was even called
laughtail and not raftel during the wano
arc as well we saw Roger and Whitebeard
clashing in their Prime we saw Roger's
Journey around the world to all the
different pornographs many in places
that the straw hats have been on their
journey to as well we saw yang sheng's
young buggy and Blackbeard and of course
Whitebeard and of course we saw kozuki
Odin his chaotic youth spends drinking
and gambling his disownment and
subsequent appointment as daimyo his
Reformation of the Lawless land of kuri
the Gathering of his retainers his
adventures out at Sea and family life
with Toki hiori and momonowski and most
importantly to the central conflict of
wano his relationship with Orochi and
kaido he was the only person so far to
scar the Monstrous Dragon a part of
kaido's and Odin's shared backstory that
did deliver characterization for the
villain that his own backstory did not
as we've discussed we had one of the
most intense and crazy Feats in all of
One Piece and an explanation for Odin's
absurd hairstyle when he held his
retainers above him while boiling in oil
Holden was indeed born to boil and this
was one of the most memorable moments in
all of One Piece I'd say now after the
Odin flashback it was time for things to
get real the rats gabbards remembering
the legacy of their Master face down
onigashima due to kinemon's hilarious
misunderstanding about the new meeting
place and time it looked as if the plan
had been foiled they would face kaido
alone the Striking panel of them framed
against the Raging Sea is one of the
best in all of wano and as if things
couldn't get any worse they were met
with the ultimate betrayal not only did
kandro lie about his allegiances he lied
about his art skills and fled with Momo
in Tao you could really feel the rest of
the scabbards utter despair as their
friend and comrade four years betrayed
them shortly after chandra's betrayal
things took a much more hopeful turn as
the alliance finally assembled with the
return of jimbei the complete strawhead
crew was officially assembled for the
first time in the series again a
wonderful and epic moment Hoda wasted no
time giving us some panel to die for
after so many arcs of our crew being
split up seeing them back together again
made the raid on onigashima feel like
pre-time Skip One Piece in a lot of ways
after focusing so much on an
ever-expanding cast of new characters it
brought us back to the central course of
the manga that is the straw hat crew now
Yamato might not have become a straw hat
but they were an immediate highlight of
the arc for me at least just like had a
Korean whole cake Islands the fan
favorite character of X3 was a powerful
son of a yonko who befriended Luffy
Yamato has an amazing merch worthy
design a wild attitude gave us some much
loved Ace backstory and was a bigger
Odin Fanboy than any one-piece fan could
ever be really here's to praying that
we'll get to see those characters soon
again some point in the story what a
moment this was I mean the red scabbards
fight against kaido ended in complete
failure really they couldn't do much of
anything to the yonko but they made one
hell of a first strike in which they all
worked together in unison to rush the
main stage and stab the scar that their
Master Odin had left behind remembering
the only man who was powerful enough to
scar him kaido was shook his regrets
surrounding his unfinished and
dishonorable fight led him to clutching
his own wound in disbelief momentarily
causing the Unstoppable Beast to pass in
unison they gave the Battle Cry of kuri
sunachi in the end predictably the
scabbards were defeated but they put
forth a valiant effort now roof piece is
where things really kicked off here in
chapter 1000 a Monumental milestone for
one piece Luffy flexed harder than he's
ever flexed by straight up casually
walking past kaido and big mom to check
on the bloody and battered scabbards
five members of the worst generation
went head to head with two of the most
powerful characters in all of One Piece
and while at first the efforts seemed
fruitless eventually they were able to
earn their Victory truly showing that a
new age of piracy has daunt and while
the entire Zorro kills kaido Theory
train was stopped hard in its tracks
here Zoro fans were still eating quite
well as The Swordsman managed to
temporarily block a combined attack from
two Emperors of the sea not only that
but zaro actually managed to cut kaido
the first person since Odin to do so now
there were a lot of really amazing and
memorable fights during the raid the
amount of One Versus once we got hacking
back to the good old days of Enos Lobby
when the straw had faced off in matchups
against the cp9 Jim Bay got his first
fight as a member of the crew finally
Zara and Sanji even had a couple of
chapters of a Duo match against king and
queen and seeing these two actually team
up momentarily is always a treat however
let's be real the standout among these
matchups was Robin vs Black Maria Nico
Robin has always been a strong character
the devil fruit despite its drawbacks is
so so versatile from day one as a member
of Baroque Works she was breaking backs
left and right but not since kaipia has
she gotten to use her skills in a real
battle only in momentary glimpses like
when she she managed to stop hakuba who
possessed Cavendish in dressrosa now
after seeing Robin rescue Sanji from
black Maria's spidery crutches we were
able to see Robin's full power on
display here for the first time since
the time skip there was a moment when we
thought black Maria's Illusions might
have tricked her with visions of clover
and Olivia however Robin is too smart to
be deceived with panty tricks like that
Robin even received a nightmarish
transformation the demonial flirt that
gloved black Maria the clutch to end all
the clutches let's really hope we get
even more Robin's fight going forward to
make up for lost time and while we're at
it a Brooke 1 vs one wouldn't hurt
either and of course it wouldn't be one
piece without some top tier comedy
either some highlights were getting to
see the full Cruise NL reaction faces
kinemon playing off the misunderstanding
of the century as a masterful plan Robin
and jimbei being the only adults on the
crew and Frankie running over big mom's
face with a freaking motorcycle and of
course the scientifically super accurate
dinosaur Powers such as Triceratops
having a built-in propeller and
brachiosauruses being able to launch
themselves out of their own body however
if you had me at gunpoint and told me to
choose just one particular hilarious
moment in the entire Arc I would just
have to go with the zaro pack this is
what happens when you have a chef
playing the role of doctor I mean Trigon
fans didn't waste any time comparing the
cook to Wolf wood who also carries a
cross filled with particularly lethal
contents and yes this Arc we learned
that Luffy is in fact Joy boy and that
rubber fruit he's had since childhood
since chapter number one is a whole lot
more than just a rubber fruit it's the
hito hitonomi model Nika named for the
sun god of the one piece worlds and
Luffy only unlocked this devil fruit
Awakening after his own death when he
was brought back he turned Pure White
couldn't stop smiling and laughing and
his heartbeat pounded in a sound that
sanisha called the drums of Liberation
in this form Luffy wasn't the only only
thing that was rubber he could turn the
ground to rubber he could turn a
lightning bolt into Rubber and most
importantly he could turn kaido into
rubber as well who knows he could even
turn this pretty cute kitten into a
rubber as well are you rubber I don't
think so what's that so you want to run
away because they haven't subscribed
that's fair enough now Luffy in gear
five because Luffy in gear 5 becomes a
cartoon come to life gaining the Absurd
power set of a Looney Tune whether it's
his eye is jumping out of his head or
contorting his body into all sorts of
malleable shapes it's clear that this
Awakening is a whole new level for Luffy
the power befitting the future king of
the Pirates and one that we can't wait
to see in action again soon and even
though the battle against kaido had
finally ended Oda just couldn't have us
leave wanna without one last major
surprise in an appearance presumably
promoting his appearance in film red
Shanks showed up in the final chapters
of wano and gave us the wildest hockey
feat we've seen in the entire series
Shanks was able to knock a marine
Admiral aramaki out of his logia form
and scare him away from the island with
nothing but a show of conquerors hockey
as if this wasn't crazy enough he did
this from miles and miles away at Sea
somehow through this use of haki he was
even able to seemingly communicate a
specific message to his opponent
something we've never considered
possible before shanks's appearance set
the stage for the final Saga and showed
us that the power ceiling is even higher
than we previously thought which is just
fan freaking tastic but then as you know
at that point we just suddenly leave
wano quite abruptly with still a lot of
unanswered questions so in part 5 we
have to talk about the remaining
Mysteries that are left unanswered in
wano even after revisiting the entire
Arc plenty of questions remain
unanswered how will our perspective of
this gargantuas Arc evolve over the
years I wonder well in the same way that
Sky Pia Daenerys have had to reckon with
this arc's renewed importance recently
we will probably look back on oda's
decisions in wano years down the line
and shower them with Newfound praise at
least I hope so so what are we still not
seeing and what do we still need to know
before we'll truly be able to fully
comprehend and appreciate wano
throughout the wano arc we learned loads
of information about the one piece World
however after this Arc we're still left
with tons of mysteries it wouldn't be
oda's writing if we didn't have two new
questions for each answer that we got so
here are the biggest questions we still
have for the final Saga at the end of
this Arc we learned courtesy of Kazuki
Sukiyaki that the ancient weapon pluton
rests deeply beneath wanokuni and on an
even more mind-blowing level the massive
walls around wano were constructed to
hide it in the first place the opening
one of those borders we've heard so much
about doesn't just refer to its
isolation but to freeing the ancient
weapon itself but the question Still
Remains What is pluton what is it
capable of and armamonoska and zonesia
somehow involved in a similar way to
Shira Hoshi and the Sea Kings it's
really unbelievable that in this r we
met a character who actually hails from
the void century and it's barely a
highlight at all now something tells me
we still have a lot to learn about Toki
whether that means she's actually still
alive somehow and propelled herself
forward in time or when we learn more
about the void Century via flashback as
a member of the Kazuki Clan the original
creators of the pornoglyphs we still
need more information on this mysterious
woman from the past now as we've
discussed in detail in the last section
kaido's backstory is super incomplete
major parts were seemingly just glossed
over and the major speculation around
this is that Oda had to admit certain
important details to avoid revealing too
much about Roxy's back hopefully when we
look back on the wano arc we'll see
kaido in a completely new light just how
we did with big Mom after whole cake
Islands why does he yearn for an
honorable death what caused his drinking
problems and why does he want to plunge
the world into war oh and how does he
know so much about Joy boy and speaking
of kaido's Baxter story we know next to
nothing still about his people the Oni
race the only confirmed member of this
mysterious race are kaido and Yamato but
there are plenty of other characters out
there with horns both on the emperor's
crew and in other places throughout the
one piece world that will raise our
suspicions as well what is the secret
behind the Oni and more importantly
where have they gone were they like the
lunarians wiped out by the world
government oh yeah and uh speaking of
the lunarians we also need to learn
about those as well we learned a lot
about the lunarians during the fight
with King for instance we now know that
they exist we also learned that they
used to inhabit the red line they have
black wings and the ability to conjure
fire spawning by the way a million fan
theories about Sanji being imbued with
lunarian DNA or Luffy who knows the name
also suggests that they hail from the
Moon much like the other winged races
probably do as well we still need to
know though why they were wiped out from
the world government and what their role
was in the past of the one piece world
now we're about to get a lot more
information about them with the new
seraphim pacifista who seemed to be
warlord clones spliced with lunarian DNA
but I guess we'll have to wait and see
how much is going to be actually
revealed in the next Arc now it's kind
of insane that we heard the name rocks
for the very first time in this Arc like
I kind of forgot that that's a thing
ever since we heard the mysterious
figure that United big mom kaido Shiki
Whitebeard under one flag the theory
Community has been hard at work trying
to figure out who rocks diesel back is
we need to know how he plays into
kaido's backstory what happened at God
Valley and most importantly just who he
is in general what is his connection to
Blackbeard and of course we can't wait
to find out more about Joy boy and the
sun Gods Nika I mean sure there's the
question of how exactly the powers were
brought into a devil fruit and inherited
by Luffy that's a question for vegapunk
I guess but we're more curious about who
these characters were during the void
Century or before the void Century even
who was joyboy why did he apologize to
the ruler of Fishman Islands what was
his connection to zunisha and what was
the terrible crime that zonesha
committed and what is joyboy's
connection to the sun god Nica are they
the same person or is Nika truly a deity
are they from the same time span like
these answers and more are sure to come
soon as we come closer and closer to the
end of one piece but we didn't get them
here in wano yet just a lot of teasing
so it has really been a long four years
it was a long 148 chapters but in the
end Juana was like any other one piece
Arc it had moments that made us laugh
moments that put us on the edge of our
seeds moment that made us cry and
moments that had us absolutely lose our
minds it also had some very
disappointing Parts especially for
everyone who kind of had expectations
for the story to go in a certain
direction and work then kind of let down
when Oda did what Oda does best and
wrote something utterly unpredictable
I'm not an exception here at all but in
spending 100 hours and re-reading this
Arc I found one thing for certain as
controversial as this Arc really is
possibly the most controversial in the
series juano is one piece we like to
praise Oda in our favorite series
unconditionally we look at arcs like
Anna's Lobby and Marine for it and hold
them up on a pedestal as peak one piece
but we can't forget the valleys that the
series contain a malign Arc like
fisherman island or thrill of Arc is
just as much part of this modern epic as
all those other arcs and even within
those arcs each of them has a blend of
good and bad stuff there are plenty of
fans with criticism of these much-loved
arcs and even the least popular arcs
have a lot of highlights in them as well
now even though amongst the most epic
moments in the series there were some
disappointments as well even though it's
controversial love it or hate it wano is
just as much part of the series that we
love isn't that right Gojo and as Gojo
said there is a a lot more to be said
about it like for example all the crazy
little details hidden within kaido's
character Arc even though we didn't get
that full backstory if that sounds
interesting to you click this video
right here